hello everyone I don't know how things
are where you live but here it's snowing
like crazy and I know by now you were
probably impressing your friends and
family with your vast knowledge of the
1959 candidates tournament but it never
hurts to learn a bit more so here is a
very interesting in from round 10 of the
1959 candidates between poll carrots and
pal Benko
so it's Paul versus Paul and it's sort
of a sort of a nice end game miniature
and it also features a very nice blunder
but I chose this game because it's it's
actually quite quite an interesting
position that arises after only 20 moves
and I'm sure it will motivate you not
not to really get angry or anything if
you lose like a really important game
because you know these are the
candidates almost every game is
important so let's see the game and
unfortunately I couldn't find a game of
Karis playing against Bank win this
tournament or the two of them playing in
any tournament so there's like not one
photo of the two of them playing so
let's see the game efore by Karis and E
5 9 f3 knight c6 and Bishop to b5 Derulo
PES we have a 6 Murphy's defence Bishop
to a4 Knight to f6 and Karis castles
Bishop to e7 rook to e1 and B 5 now
Bishop to b3 and d6 we have c3 castles
and we have a ch3 here Knight back to b8
we have d4 and Bishop to b7 and now what
Bishop to b7 Benko is attacking d4 pawn
twice but it also allows carriers to
grab d5 pawn and exchange Queens and
this is exactly what carries goes for D
captures on e5 d captors on e5 Queen
captures Bishop captures and now Knight
captures on e5 and now Benko grabs d4
pawn Knight captures on e4 we have
Bishop to e3 and now you have to you
have to figure out what to do with black
the material is equal and both players
still have the Bishop repair so only a
couple of points have been exchanged and
black has to figure out how to develop
you can't really play something like
rook to e8 the f7
one is really weak so you have to figure
out what to do I'm like Knight to c6 is
possible but it it requires a lot of
calculation after a move like Bishop to
d5 now attacking this Knight twice and
this knight on e4
so probably Knight to a5 now defending
the bishop on b7 also another Bishop is
attacking the bishop on on d5 and after
Bishop captures an e4 Bishop captures
and now Bishop to c5 attacking the rook
on f8 and also attacking the bishop on
e4 so after rook e8 rook captures now
first to play Knight to b7 to attack the
undefended Bishop on c5 bishop moves and
now f6 winning back the piece but after
92 pawn captures and rook to e1 still a
better position for white but definitely
something to consider in this position
this Knight to c6 move in the game banco
decided to go for Bishop to f6 he
attacks Karis knight on e5
we had Knight to g4 and now Knight to d7
and again you can see that banker did
develop his pieces and now the bishop is
on f6 and the knight here is on d7 and
here you can see the tension between
this night and g4 and the bishop on f6
and when whenever there's the tension
between pieces it always favors the
player who can break the tension so
Karis can always decide to capture on f6
where Benko can't really decide anything
as long as it's like this this is in
Karis favor so Harris goes night to D -
we have Knight captures the Bishop
captures and now rook F to e8 so
attacking I mean developing the rook
placing it on a nice open e-file we had
Bishop to a4 now attacking the c7 point
that is undefended rook captures only
one rook captures anyone and now rook
the c8 defending the c7 pawn and here we
have Bishop to c2 and Bishop the c2 is
is is a really powerful move wood bishop
the c2
Carris is now threatening Bishop to f5
and would Bishop to a5 he would be
attacking the knight on d7 and also the
knight would be pinned as there's a
rockin c8 so how do you prevent this
well there are a couple of ways to
prevent this best idea for best idea for
black would be to play h5
but even after play playing h5 white
will not capture the bishop if you
capture and capture then black is
perfectly fine you don't really have the
option of going Ruby 7 because nice to
d5 will attack both the rook and the
bishop on e4 the problem is after this
h5 move a Karass will still play Bishop
to a5 and now it's simply much better
for white with pawn captures now the
should capture some d7 attacking the
rook and c8 rook moves and now Bishop
captures and g4 so both players would
still have the bishop pair one rook each
and caris would be a Pathan whether
banco could play this to a draw it's
hard to say probably not but you know
it's it's the best thing he could have
gone for in this position but after this
Bishop to c2 banco does something which
a lot of players often do in difficult
positions he wanted to hang out - hang
on to everything like if you've seen
that game I made between petrol petrol
Simon Smith Slav Petrosyan also wanted
to hang out hang on to everything he
pushed g3 instead of giving up one pawn
and then Smigiel completely crushed him
here
Ben Cole plays a terrible movie it's a
blunder that instantly loses the game he
plays g6 with the idea of moving the
Bishop to g7 maybe bringing the knight
to f6 next and of course now the g6 pawn
is preventing the bishop from coming to
f5 but again oops sorry
like I said g6 is a terrible blunder
that loses the game so this is the
position you are playing the Polaris I
mean you are Polaris win this game with
white so what move do you play that
instantly wins the game I mean of course
I do hope you pause the video and try to
find the move for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent player and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
the Mulcair is played was rook to d1 and
after rook to d1 pal Benko resigned the
as you can see the night the night on d7
is attacked and there is no way you can
prevent the both threats of this night
and d7 being attacked and the bishop on
f6 being attacked so the threat is
pretty simple simply rook captures night
and then night captures Bishop and
there's there's a really no way to
prevent it if you if you defend it then
it's still the same thing then it's even
worse after this trick then the king and
rook are forked and after the King moves
you grab even the rook and it's
completely over so I have to work to D
one bank Oh unfortunately had to resign
the game and this is move 21 so you know
a very nice game by Paul Paul Harris and
I don't have to mention it since you'll
probably already know this in this
tournament
Banquo one last place which you can see
here here we have Paul Banco with 8
points out of 28 and Karis won second
place with 18 and a half points out of
28 so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it it was very short but it's
like I said hey I'm sure it will be very
motivational for you when you make such
a blunder in a very important game you
know happens to the best of them I would
like to thank Joseph cuprous I mean
although it could be cooporation in
Micronesia in corporate and Blais lejana
for a contribution to my channel think a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon and have a great weekend of
course